joining us now on the Dan Patrick show
from NBCSN Mike Florio Mike right off
the bat I want to get a topic with you
does a little off base here but any
reaction on your show to Dunkin Donuts
switching to just Dunkin how'd that play
out this morning well first let me say
this that was a fascinating baseball
conversation why do you guys continue
that I'll hang up and not listen Mike
you what was last time you watched a
baseball game from start to finish
never I spent years it's been so long I
can't remember I don't think up does
anybody ever watch it on any game from
start to finish I mean even if you're at
the game you really watch the game if
you're there you really pay attention
nah I never heard watch tonight any game
start to finish on playoffs like I got a
roll with you there
I got it we got a roll all right poll
question Perloff give it to Mike Florio
okay what should the NFL do about the
hit rule should they change the rule
should they just quietly ease back on
calling it as much or should they leave
it as is well here's the problem they
can't change it because the only way you
can change a rule is to have 24 owners
in the confines of a meeting arranged by
the NFL either hope to change it or not
vote to change it so they have to do
what they did last month remember when
they had all the issues with lowering
the helmet style and they they had a
competition committee conference call
and they announced after that we are not
changing the rule and then in the next
set how they're changing the rule so I
think something like that's going to
happen here where the rule doesn't
change but they're going to try to
strike a better balance between
protecting quarterbacks and getting away
from this constant crush of criticism
from coaches and players and media and
fans and I don't know how far they're
going to push it the other way you know
what they're trying to do they're trying
to avoid the situation that they're
going to have four times between week
six and week ten with the 49ers where CJ
Beathard is starting a game in prime
time instead of Jimmy Garoppolo now
Garofalo injured himself but this is why
the NFL is trying to protect
quarterbacks they don't want another
Aaron Rodgers collarbone if they can
avoid it they don't want quarterback
injuries that can be avoided but now
with all this criticism I think they're
gonna find a way to maybe push it back a
little bit and and here's what you know
what to do with the catch rule they said
well here are the catches that should
have been catches so let's change the
rule to make sure these will be catches
in the future I think they're gonna look
at the hits that they
should have been roughing the passer and
adjust the the emphasis the enforcement
the interpretation so those penalties in
the future wouldn't be rough in the past
Mike I know Aaron Rodgers obviously
sells more than a William Hayes but how
much concern should the league have
about these defensive guys trying to do
everything they can to land or credly so
they don't land right on top of the
quarterback and then they're injuring
themselves and now they're out for the
year going through surgery I think the
league would just look at it frankly and
shrug
I mean look plenty of times guys hit the
ground they step to do something and
there's a risk that when you do it
you're going to injure yourself what the
league wants these guys to do when
they're about to hit a quarterback is
roll them to the ground
tase hit derrick karr the way that you
know you typically see a guy who's gonna
lay on top of the quarterback hit him
and then almost like it hits you realize
oh wait I'm gonna get penalized if I
land on and so let me try to not land on
it I think well until they change the
rule
coaches need to be teaching these guys
and they need to be running drills where
you know you've got that that tackling
dummy that's robotic and it rolls around
and and you can you know you can make it
move I think they need to get these guys
to learn how to hit a quarter but I kind
of from the side and get them down that
way instead of smashing them that's what
the NFL and I think even if they change
the rule they're not going to change
that aspect of the bodyweight because
that's how you you enhance the risk of
injury so yeah and between their car
getting injured and William Hayes
getting injured the NFL is going to take
a William Hayes getting injured one
hundred out of a hundred times hey Mike
how does it work logistically if they do
want to tell officials not to do it Dan
it hinted that maybe the officials in
the league weren't totally on the same
page with this rule and the officials
were calling a little tighter than the
league may have wanted does out River on
just sort of make a phone call and send
out videos and the officials act on it
or is there more to it well I mean
here's what happened to Terry McCauley
who's now the Sunday Night Football
rules analyst he was still an NFL
referee back in May when they got
together and they played the video and
they told them how they want these these
roughing the passer calls to be made and
he got the impression that the referees
were going to have a lot of discretion
to either call it or not call it and you
know what happens is when there's a call
like the one we saw last week claim that
you sit on Kirk cause
allow the Vikings to force overtime I
don't think the NFL really believed in
that one as much as the NFL believe in
the Clay Matthews file this past week
when he landed on top of Alex Smith I
think I think that that they're not
going to publicly criticize a referee
for falling roughing the passer but I
think that they're going to defer to
their discretion if they call it and
that's going to be the challenge because
in real times yeah without the benefit
of replay and you may have bodies in the
way between the referee and the
quarterback I guys are sitting the
quarterback how do you how do you have a
clear bright line
this is roughing the passer this isn't
buffing the passer and I think that's
always Mike Florio football talk at NBC
Sports joining us now not what you think
is going to happen but if you were Dirk
cutter the coach of the Buccaneers how
would you handle the quarterback
situation in the current time like right
now and going forward well without
question you have to go with Ryan
Fitzpatrick this weekend against the
Chicago Bears Jameis Winston just
returned yesterday from a three-game
suspension and in those three games and
I still can't like my brain wants to
reject this like a body rejecting a
transplanted organ that Ryan Fitzpatrick
is the first player in NFL history to
have three straight 400 yard passing
games like wait a minute surely Dan
Marino did this surely Dan foul did this
surely Drew Brees has done this five
times but no Ryan Fitzpatrick is the
first guy to do it you can't put him on
the bench the way he's been playing the
real question comes after the Chicago
game they have a pie then they play the
Falcons how does Fitzpatrick play on
Sunday when do you flip from Fitzpatrick
back to Winston and that's going to be
the challenge because you know if it's
Patrick has a rough game like he had
that rough first half on Monday night
when do you say it's Winston it reminds
me a lot of last year when the Vikings
were holding Teddy Bridgewater over Case
Keenum for the second half of the season
and it just felt like he was one mistake
away from Bridgewater coming in when do
you do that because once you do it and
you're kind of stuck right you can't
flip back so I think it's gonna be a
real challenge for cutter to figure out
the right time to make a change one of
the stories I don't think is getting
enough coverage is Earl Thomas the star
safety for the Seattle Seahawks he's
basically wagging the dog out there
saying hey I know you need me to win
you know you need me to win
you decided you weren't gonna pay me so
I won't show up bunch of practice or
I'll practice what I want to but what
are you do bench me because you need me
on Sunday do you think this could catch
on with the high-end players in the NFL
well I mean there is a risk that if
you're too disruptive if you get
yourself fine for contract detriment of
the team they can eventually suspend you
up to four games and and that it's the
Terrell Owens situation from 2005 where
he decided that he wanted a new contract
or he wanted to be traded the Eagles
said we're not doing either so he was
going to be as disruptive as he needed
to be to convince the team to just rip
the band-aid off and get rid of him and
I think are all Thomas is trying to do
that but the problem for him is if he
pushes it too far he's going to start
losing money and that's the balance he
has to strike and you know from the
seahawks perspective they have to ask
themselves how aggressively do we want
to push this because you know we don't
we got enough issues right now we don't
need these distractions on top of it so
you know I think he'd love to get traded
to a team that will sign in to a new
contract
give him the security he thinks he
deserves but let's remember this is a
safety market that you know the money
isn't falling from the sky like it is
for pass rushers at quarterback so I
don't know what he can really get at his
age and when looking at team is going to
have to give up a fairly high draft pick
to get him that's just less money to be
willing to pay him so he may have to
play out this season to become a free
agent and see what's out there on the
market that's large Steelers running
back levy on bail still holding out
reported this weekend that Steelers
listening the trade offers anything
happening in there mic is anyone calling
the Steelers with anything real one
Manish matter The Daily News reported
that the Jets have talked to the
Steelers about it but this is a
complicated transaction because first
you have to be willing to do a partial
year rental deal with Le'Veon Bell
because you can't sign him to a
long-term contract you can't sign them
to anything other than I want your deal
until after the season ends so you have
to get the Steelers to give him up so
what are the Steelers want form second
round kick okay we're going to get up to
second round pick now we have to
convince lady LFL to show up and sign a
contract so he can be traded in the
first place because until he shows up
inside there's nothing to trade so
what's his lady on bail want well he's
not playing for 850 five thousand a week
he wants more than that in order to to
assume the physical risk that he's
blow his opportunity to get a big
contract on the open market so what does
it take does it take a million to a week
does it take a million three a week who
knows but those are things that if
you're the Jets for example you got to
figure out what are the Steelers want
what is Belle want and are we willing to
do all of that for a guy that we have no
guarantee we're going to keep beyond the
end of the regular season I think it's
too much to expect one team to make all
those sacrifices and the real question
becomes the Steelers are now willing to
consider trading him when they weren't
two weeks ago if they can't trade him do
they ever send the franchise attack
before he shows up and signs it and I
think that that they have to seriously
consider doing that because talk about
distractions if he comes in and he
doesn't want to play because his
hamstring sore because he has a headache
and you know and they think he may be
embellishing like James Harrison
suggests he should you just don't want
that as you're trying to make a run to
the closed seat
alright flourescent stands out I want to
hip you to something that happens in our
studio every day we watch your show
every morning
and whenever you have Chris Sims in is
your co-host every day then walks by the
TV screen it goes top button top buttons
buttoned and he has some type of trance
fiction or whatever word you want to use
with Chris Sims having his top button on
whatever shirt he's wearing buttoned
have you ever wanted to during one of
those arguments you in Sims have when
you're jabbing back and forth want to
just grab him by that little smarmy top
button and unbuttoned and have you
thought about it oh I thought about it
many times and you've given me an
inspiration because during football
season we're together on Monday so I'm
gonna have to do something there and
force him to unbutton that but I mean
that's do you have some kind of tattoo
there what what it what is what are you
hiding under that button and he his
position is he's done it since he was
eight years old and he's not changing it
now so that that's his thing and yeah
I've got used to it I mean because I've
been dealing with it for so long now but
yeah I I every once in a while I see
that thing and it's like my god like
what is your deal but that that's his
trademark and yeah well I mean you know
hey better him than me although I think
I think once or twice I button my top
button just to mock it but I know I
can't do it five seconds so Mike I know
you don't want to talk baseball but see
deny during the break we're having a
heated Jimmy Butler debate I assume you
want to get in on that should you know
is he another one
you don't know I know Jimmy Butler long
snapper for the Patriots yeah Butler by
the way seen his copy the guy lives down
the street from me when I was growing up
Jimmy Buffett Jimmy how you been yeah
maybe that's when you're all in on one
sport I just I don't have the time or
the desire I'll pay attention to the
hockey and the playoffs but other than
that it's very very casual I mean basic
I mean I was a big Pirates fan when I
was a kid I couldn't tell you the name
of one player Andrew McCutchen is the
only player I could tell you for the
Pirates seed his top button right now by
the way just after that talk I was like
you know what I could pull off some army
top button and I think I'm gonna give it
a shot for the next 20 minutes see how
it goes smarmy talk button I like the
name smarmy top but I think if I use
that enough it'll shame him into opening
it up yeah I sense a sponsorship for
your show Mike thanks a lot for joining
us Mike Florio NBCSN for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]